reading and listening are both powerful
ways to learn a language they are also
powerful goals of learning a language we
want to read we want to understand what
we hear we want to understand movies and
yet the fact of reading in the language
and listening in the language helps us
learn the language but then the question
always comes up should we read first or
listen first or people say I don't
understand anything how can I listen I
don't know any words how can I read how
do I get started so I want to talk today
about the strategies that I use for
reading and listening and when it's
important to read first when it's
important to listen
first first of all reading and it's a
tremendous cognitive feat for the brain
to be able to read so the idea that we
can convert the writing lines on a page
into meaning is pretty amazing what's
also interesting and this was pointed
out recently in a short video that I saw
by Andrew huberman but it's something
that I have experienced myself and that
is when we read we
subvocalize we actually voice what we're
reading if one were to put an amplifier
or to measure the firing of those
muscles in our vocal cords we'd find
that as we're reading information we are
actually speaking that information
that's not the same as speaking speaking
means creating sentences thoughts
utterances where we are drawing on our
ability in the language our memory of
the language our model of the language
that's speaking simply reading out loud
or sub vocalizing actually is not
speaking but it's a very good way to
move you in the direction of being able
to speak so if reading is connected to
subvocalizing and we also know that
essentially the same parts of the brain
are involved in reading or listening if
we're going to read and we're going to
sub vocalize we have to know what those
words or how they are pronounced to some
extent even if we pronounce them poorly
so that would suggest suggest that we
should begin by listening so that we get
a sense of how the words are pronounced
so that we can then effectively
subvocalize while
reading in simple terms I would divide
my sort of strategy or approach to
listening and reading and the order in
which I do them into three stages so the
absolute beginner stage call it A1 to A2
stage then the sort of intermediate
stage which is B1 really cuz once you're
at B2 you're kind of launched and then
once I'm at B2 or beyond what is my
strategy at the very beginning I look at
a sentence of finish as you will see I
see words if these words are written in
the Latin alphabet or an alphabet that
I'm familiar with I can kind of
pronounce it but as you'll see in
Finnish I can't really pronounce it the
way it's pronounced in Finnish but I can
kind of make an effort to do so so
therefore as a beginner I would first of
all go at this text in sentence views so
one sentence at a time and then I would
listen to that
sentence and then I would try to read
that
sentence so the order would be listen
first then read but very soon again
dealing with one sentence at a time I
would try to force myself to read first
and then listen because we can get lazy
if I listen to it then I'm not trying
hard enough to vocalize those sounds so
I would typically say if I'm doing the
mini stories maybe after mini story two
or three I would try to make an attempt
at pronouncing the sentence in Finnish
because I can read the Latin alphabet
then I would listen to it and then I
would say it again and so this is
building up my capability to subvocalize
so that I can read more and more
difficult material remember that all of
the skills that we develop through
whatever practices we engage in we're
gradually building up our ability in the
language it's very similar to what
happens in AI exposure to a lot of
different contexts is going to help us
almost predict what's coming at us and
being able to predict is also both in
the case of artificial intelligence and
in the case of learning a language is an
important part of us getting a sense
sort of a model of what that language is
so that's at the beginner stage one
sentence at a time starting off
listening first then read then listen
then read
again the next stage and by by the way
this idea of having a reading and
listening strategy that depends on the
stage you are in the language I think is
a good thing to try to do but the point
there is that whether we're reading or
listening we are in fact kind of doing
the same thing and the two learning
activities and the two goals of our
learning very much work hand inand if we
look now at the intermediate stage
obviously it's easier to listen first I
get up in the morning the easiest thing
for me to do is to listen to something
so I'll go grab a pock podcast let's say
in in farsy while I'm listening to that
there is quite a bit there that I didn't
understand or that I'm kind of familiar
with the words but I'm not entirely sure
what they mean so that then triggers my
curiosity to go and read that transcript
which I can now do automatically in link
using our whisper AI so in that
situation where I'm B one and a half in
Persian I tend to listen and then later
on I'll go in and read also this issue
of intensive reading versus extensive
reading intensive reading you're looking
up every word you're going over the
sentence a few times extensive reading
you're just reading and the same applies
to listening now I have found that at
the beginning stage for me it's not
possible to just you know go straight
into extensive reading not looking
anything up just listening I can't do it
I have to have a certain level of
vocabulary a certain level of
familiarity to be able to move to more
extensive reading and listening no
longer in sentence mode perhaps
certainly not repeating what I'm reading
or listening and maybe I don't even have
to read what I listen to I can read over
here and listen over here and all the
while I'm building up my capability in
the language so the further we are along
in the language the more we have a
tendency to not repeat to not go back
and it's better for us not to repeat I
just wanted to talk a little bit about
because the question always comes up do
you listen first to read first and I
think this very much depends on your
level in the language where you are in
the language what you like to do it's in
your interest I think to develop a taste
for both listening and reading because
the greater the variety of Paths of
formats that we use the better for us
makes things more interesting and I
think we learn better that way